Continuing
in
the book of purification,
the chapter regarding endeavors, the
etiquets of relieving oneself and the
etiquets of the area or place which we
would call the restroom.
of relieving oneself.
He says, "And it is impermissible
for an individual to relieve himself
either in a path that is used
or
under
people's shade."
In people's shade. What does this mean?
Meaning where people go to sit.
There's a tree there. They go to sit
down. There's shade there.
Person uses the restroom there.
Or a place where people walk. Person
uses the restroom there. Relieves
himself in the path or in a place where
people sit.
Now the author mentions these two
things.
the path
or the shape of people.
But that is because the author's
methodology in writing this book is to
stick to exactly what the narration
usually says exactly.
But if we were to extrapolate the true
extent of this narration that we are
about to read,
is it only in these two places?
Meaning in a place where people seek
shade or in a place where people used to
walk. What about say a place where
people seek warmth a bus a bus stop
right in in in cold places or let's say
a place where people seek comfort
a park bench or let's say all of this
is intended.
What's intended is relieving oneself in
a place that harms other people. This is
what's intended by the narration. And
the two most common places
that will harm people is either in a
path that is used by people or in sh in
shade that is used by people place where
people sit. Right? This is the true
spirit of the narration.
So whilst the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam does mention the path and the
shade
the true spirit of the narration is much
more broad than that.
[Silence]
Muslim.
He says,
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said, "Beware of the two
oursed
acts or the two oursed places, the two
things that will garner the curse of
Allah."
So they said, "Oh messenger of Allah,"
they companions, they said, "Oh
messenger of Allah, and what are the two
accursed acts?"
He said, "The one who relieves himself
in a people's path or in their shade."
Meaning he relieves himself in a path
that they use or in the place where they
seek shade under a nice tree. See a
place where people usually sit. I
think this is common as human beings. We
have canopies. We have things that we
create in order to give us shade or a
nice opportune
tree that we might sit under a place
where people will commonly go to relieve
themselves.
The scholars of Phil have extrapolated
from this narration
that it is not permissible to relieve
oneself under a tree that bears fruit
even if people don't use it for shade or
to relieve oneself
under a tree that is used for some
utility etc.
Why? because this will inadvertently
harm other people. And it's called the
two occursed places
because when a person walks by and steps
in something,
they will say,
right? And so a person garers the curse
and the dua of other people upon
himself.
Hence the point is is that it is not
permissible for a person to relieve
himself in any place that will harm
other people whether by touch, by smell,
by sight.
Because al
is not just that which harms. No, al is
that which annoys.
This is referred to as
we know the narration of the prophet
Muslim.
Right.
That one of the branches of faith is
removing the annoyance from the path.
The ever is an annoyance.
And so it's not that which harms, it is
that which annoys. And an annoyance can
be what?
Smell,
sight,
touch.
you know something that is an eyesore.
This is considered to be what? Ana. So
when a person relieves himself, if they
relieve themsel at the expense of others
at the expense of others harm or at the
expense of others
annoyance, this is considered to be a
this is considered to be one of the
prohibitions
in the etiquets of relieving oneself.
cover.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.